buonasera tutte di voi oggi brevissimo
pretendo un po l'esperienza legata
sostenibilità nella città del futuro
cercando di naro di produzione ha un
aspetto che ancora marginalmente abbiamo
toccato noi quando siamo nati come
realtà siamo nati cercando di rispondere
a una domanda per come è possibile
conciliare un accelerazione intervento
nel quotidiano network rail
nell'esistenza le gambe alla sostenere i
principi di sophie lista a proposito
invece di sostenibilità su un contesto
dove il lavoro ed economia e comunque
ponderate per questo è un grosso ma che
investe interamente dunque piantare con
un sistema economico che ci ha sorpresi
e nei quali volenti o nolenti siamo
capelli quindi nascita e ovvero che ci
sono posti è stato come intervenire in
quel contesto quest'ottica partendo
dall'inizio
diciamo prima piazza e abbiamo avuto
diverse esperienze anche singole è
arrivata da social trading co di base
gli ambientalisti alcuni di noi nella
militanza di base
nei movimenti della pace quindi barghe
idro gene è un certo punto si sono
incontrate si sono poste il potere ma ok
che faccio da grande come faccio anche a
conciliare una grande parte della mia
vita che l'aspetto dedicata al lavoro
con navigazione
i principi che devono associando
esprimere una cercare di rendere
concreti quest'ottica nel 94 un primo
abbozzo di dea con la colazione di
un'associazione che è una associazione
tesa a cercare di costruire di darsi un
idea e l'inizio è stata nato ma giovedì
una realtà associativa della quale si è
maturata da fine l'idea credito
un'esperienza lavorativa
l'esperienza lavorativa che si
concretizza nel 99 sono nati nel 99 con
la nascita della ribera l'esperienza di
impresa di impresa cooperativa di
impresa cooperativa sociale network che
operi questo già all'epoca
sociale bruciata ad affermarsi la grande
novità è cosi che è andato a fondare la
rete da
un'impresa cooperativa sociale integrata
per che operasse nel campo della
sostenibilità e non solo nel campo della
sostenibilità sociale perché diciamo che
prima di noi in questo momento
in italia non esistevano cooperative che
l'accesso a tutte le cose che operasse
nel campo della sostenibilità sociale ma
anche ambientale in particolare sul
fronte di ciò che facciamo tutto in
fonte ai fratelli energetica delle fonti
energetiche nel 2001 quindi dopo due
anni di attività che stava cominciando
impostare a manifestare ha portato ad
esempio a ricevere il premio europeo
della green job quindi della volta è
come riconoscimento del lavoro nel 2003
anche sulla spinta del della nostra
esperienza
comincia maestro di una volta comincia
la nasce in italia
alla fine sociali integrande e si
occupano di ponte globale o di rifarmi
nel cerchio cui una serie tutta l'inizio
abbiamo sostenuto la nascita di questa
realtà
quali sono i punti da bill e ad
affrontare innanzitutto l'essere senza
scopo di lucro fondamentali
di azioni sul conto economico è stata
fin da subito da una priorità se
facciamo solo noi devo analizzare da una
priorità al lavoro rispetto al profitto
quindi non essere finalizzata alla
creazione di potito ma lontane ad
apprezzare di lavori né una di
neoliberismo effetti questi filiali
stiamo vedendo credo che sia una cosa
conto corrente ed è anche un po la
nostra idea di posizione su quello che
deve essere la città del signore la
citta di tibu restare qualcosa una città
dove comunque la priorità è il lavoro
della persona anche altre priorità
interamente su quell'aspetto di
economico dare lavoro e più importante
lavoro solidale lavoro inclusivo di
collaborazione un nuovo che componga
tecnologie ecologiche
questo è soltanto il 3 minardi quindi
tecnologia copiate e sappiamo o e i
cambiamenti del quotidiano è seduto
labor solidaretà come stessi punti
cardine sono sempre stati la difesa
dell'ambiente e in una zona economica
intesa come albero nata con un milione
una differente un idea un certo senso lo
slot che abbiamo sempre usato energie da
condividere abbiamo dell'energia e delle
competenze non siamo tuttologi ma
abbiamo umani nelle cose queste colpe
detto che a condividere è un futuro da
presentare ad ora per levare anche in
un'ottica ambientale sono l'economia
stenta un'economia ecologica un'economia
che nutre in un'economia che quando mi
ha dato quello che serve si fa quindi
non abbiamo ambizioni di sviluppo di
crescita così con un principio di base
che è un altro modo è possibile lo
slogan che stessero dare un atomo è
possibile noi abbiamo preferito dire un
altro modo è possibile cercare di
applicare questo aspetto non solo
pensare sognarla
futuro mai dire io posso fare il napoli
è significa risata poi
bello di nome la casella è quella
piantina di disegnata la ripresa video è
una pianta che si trova nel nostro
territorio dei castelli romani margini
dei campi in passato utilizzato fino
agli anni 50 con il canta vittoria corso
piantata su dava per tingere di giallo i
tessuti può soppiantare da una cultura e
derivati da gregorio quindi già il nome
e significante tutti nomi sono significa
anche la scelta del nove per è stato
significate recuperare qualcosa di
piccolo che c'è distribuito che
calpestiamo quando facciamo le
passeggiate ma che è importante è stato
importante può ritornare essere
importante
l'ambito questi anni con tanto se una
realtà piccola realtà piccola come
numero di persone sviluppato sinergie in
ambito internazionale
molti potenti di gara europeo sia
legati gli altri progetti sostenuti
dalla commissione europea passato da
programmi a tenerla adesso da programma
intelligent energy e questa
giurisdizione internazionale
domani a 60 sempre importante che
piccola realtà che si deve in
partnership ad altre realtà scambi
quindi sono da 100 di scambio con altre
esperienze altre esperienze più avanzate
oppure altri modi di fare le cose di
popolazione alle soluzioni che non si
potevano pensare e cercare di portare
sul territorio dato importante
lì ci dovrà essere una cooperativa
sociale integrata parte dei miei
colleghi questa è la caratteristica
tutte le cooperative sociali integrati
dovrebbe essere la caratteristica
principale quella che ci alcuni napoli
cooperative che parte dei miei colleghi
sono persone svantaggiate
in particolare parte dei miei colleghi
sono casuali e così la stabilità persone
con diverse abilità dove lavoro con i
miei colleghi di lavoro io non sono un
costoso pittorica lo ha detto il
minatore e quindi sono i miei colleghi
che partecipano alla costruzione della
vita sociale della cooperativa ea della
vita lavorativa della copertina i
processi docente decisionali mi perdo
della cooperativa
l'altro aspetto non è sempre stato
importante
l'ottica è stato quello della formazione
caso formazione tecnica e professionale
fin da subito abbiamo cercato di
diffondere quello che sapevamo una
cultura tecnica con un'idea che la
conoscenza deve essere distribuita ed
essere distribuita perché se l'obiettivo
è favorire l'utilizzo di tecnologia
previdente io devo dare gli strumenti
affinché questa si riporta è inutile
potrete poi non c'è nessuno che le
s'applica quindi l'aspetto della
formazione per noi è stato sempre
essenziale un'ottica distribuiti
distribuzione della conoscenza e di
informazione di collaboratori non mi
competitori il diverso modo di
affrontare collaborazione non potessero
l'innovazione tecnologica
i progetti queste questo e sly ad
esempio particolare due un progetto
sperimentale 4 al di fatto il
politecnico di milano sul raffrescamento
solare o la partecipazione di tasca e
dell'agenzia internazionale
dell'energia e del lavoro anche vip alla
condivisione del sapere e la ricerca
made e coscienti di attività di capaci
di verdi di educazione ambientale quindi
ampio arco che attività che si bottino a
sant'ippolito per citarne alcune
esperienze recenti indicative le azioni
che eco logica dell'integrazione di cibo
questo programma che abbiamo finito per
young ha investito di valersi carceri
italiane di solarizzazione dei termini
italiani in particolare su liberilibri
c'è stata una formata di 307 1.100
detenuti con formazione di altre realtà
che poi molte di queste persone hanno
piante attività lavorative una volta
uscite
o costi attività formative rivolte a
migranti del territorio che con questo
post che vedete questa foto due ragazzi
del bangladesh sono ritornati in patria
che hanno aperto una una testa che fa
socializzazione dei pali continua a
rimanere in contatto e mi dice tallinn
riporto di conoscenza interiore e ora
ora in realtà quello che sta spingendo
come dylan e la nostra esperienza
comunque più di dieci danni che ci siamo
cercare ancora di giudico di utilizzarla
e di andare verso una rete l'economia
positiva con altri soggetti economici o
pone in atto voto nardo il vedere di
riuscire a creare un distretto di lascio
ricordiamo quando siamo nati stavano
nascendo anche i primi anni ci davano
dei fatti perché se avete stato un
fallimento farla divina
l'operazione un attività di inclusione
sociale all'interno dei loro conti è
un'attività di ecologia sospesi perché
da quanto tutti i principi del foro si
sbagliano perché possiamo ancora ampi
che alcuni di quelli che ci davano per
spacciati in nascita non ci sono più